Do you guys remember this viral massager?
It's gonna go viral again
when Black Friday and Cyber Monday come around,
everybody's thinking of, what can I buy?
What can I buy? You know,
gifts for their family members.
This thing is a fucking classic.
People have been buying massagers and shit like this
for back relief for all of time.
This is such a fucking classic gift.
Right now, it's almost 50% off.
There's a $6 off coupon, and there's free shipping.
So if you have somebody that you need to be getting gifts for,
this back massager is the perfect gift.
And because it comes with the car adapter,
I use this thing on a fucking road trip.
It was a godsend. It's linked right here if you want one.
Don't miss out on the sales.